i want to i want to be personally i want
to personally first of all congratulate
you on your very colorful outfit
well it's just blue and a lot of decals
on it a lot of details
yeah because you're into race cars so
it's what you shoot on a race car right
sure
and you look at your body as a race car
a little bit right yes you're training
trimming up a little bit getting thick i
want to welcome the covet kid back
kobe kid is back kid is bad pose covered
body looks good on you
he's lost he's lost he looks do you look
about 220 you look 220
and you told me you were 264 which which
i'm having trouble believing that's
why are you having trouble because
that's dense that's dense those are big
numbers
and your body doesn't look like you're
carrying that but you got those yeah
about two like i'd say 230. yeah you got
to lose i thought you lost probably 30
pounds
you got the samoan
but i'm not trying i wasn't trying to
get that low well you got that samoan
how's that taste and smell daddy
non-existent
yeah yeah it sucks that's the worst part
about it besides the fact that you're
coughing and can't get it no the worst
part was not the
loss of taste and smell it was the body
the shakes the shakes the old shake the
old shakes like i'm sitting here like
yeah old shake stop shaking but you had
it for how long
uh i think two two weeks straight mm-hmm
you're ready today
where you thought you got it when we i
did i did
think uh when we were in um what was
that
santorini oh phoenix phoenix right i
thought i got in phoenix
well um madame kovid
she'll she'll come at your your calves
show you
she'll work her way up to your your
quads your hammies
get you in the eyeballs get you in the
eyeballs my eyes [ __ ] hurt
me hit me isolated hit me in the back of
the head at one point and my lower back
was like you know what i'm gonna [ __ ]
with the back of your head and your
lower back i'm gonna seize that area up
for you
mm-hmm and mine was the pressure on the
eyes man like
the back of my eyeballs hurt like right
here's my eyes and hurt but i feel like
you were okay for the most part oh yeah
yeah yeah
not nice healthy not the kid yeah see i
was not we are also
older and that's who kobe likes the
older folks like the older folks
especially those folks that won't stop
moving
keep doing things working out a little
bit around the house i'm gonna do a
couple deadlifts
that matters wait you did that while you
were coveting i couldn't i
yeah i try to like see how far i can
push it and then you're doing goddamn
covida is like oh
oh you're being disrespectful now like i
think i
so many people were like oh dude before
it like went wild
i was so sick i had covered like dude
like
early january last year my favorite
[ __ ] thing no you didn't that means
no
so that's fine but everybody else has
had in here it's another story the
people
we almost died what happened the boat
was coming we did this yeah
i'm already out because you didn't die
what when you got the way you got
through it man
i did get through it it was it was not
easy yeah
that shit's humbling so bad i i i
do first of all [ __ ] soup i'm not going
to eat soup
yeah soup is trash soups yeah yeah it
was
well it was tough to eat because it
would make me sweat too like it is 100
degrees out here yeah so i'm like what
am i doing like eating just eating soup
so
i stopped eating soup i just started
doing the protein drinks oh those ones
from costco mm-hmm what's going on
premier protein protein they're nice
that was all i could do really it's
all of it is all of it is i assume you
[ __ ] your pants everywhere too on that
on that oh yeah yeah that all liquid
diet
oh yeah oh she she was like let's [ __ ]
around with you she gets in there let's
move around
let's say oh man i'm covered i was like
do you like lava out of your ass i was
like i guess
like how does that
no choice no choice no you have to just
take it it's like a flamethrower's on
your [ __ ] that's right this your
[ __ ] the whole time's going
i'm exhausted please no more i it's
when you get sick there's a couple
things one it's humbling
because you realize just you are so
flesh and bone and such immortal
it that that a little invisible germ can
bring you to your [ __ ] knees
and and here's the other thing when you
get covered or even just a bad flu
like my girl got a bad flu well she
wasn't cold
she had a bad baby
my girl got the chicken pox the chicken
pox she's in her 30s yeah
she's 13. she got she got moms yeah
my girlfriend went about 15 years ago
she got mumps she got [ __ ] mumps what
yep out of nowhere just [ __ ] it was
it was the weirdest thing but
here's the other thing when you get sick
when you get a cold or whatever
and nothing's gonna help like you just
gotta power through it don't give me
your herbs your echinacea
it doesn't oh yeah that that [ __ ]
doesn't work it helps not
here's the other thing i realized when i
got covered and i i was actually this
when we were out there
you realize with all the sim stuff you
realize oh this is definitely man-made
oh this was artificially created in that
i don't think yeah oh yeah like there's
it's nothing like a cold
flu no none of that stuff no no that's
not a flu no
you can tell like this [ __ ] was man-made
because i rarely get sick
i'm not a person that gets sick all the
time right and to feel that
for just two weeks straight yeah it's
like
like you're [ __ ] up every day yeah
it's not it's it's not like a regular
like something you'd catch from i feel
like a bat this [ __ ] was
definitely engineering no one bought the
best yeah it was like
even the chinese were like who the [ __ ]
is eating was it why is it messing
uh no here's what didn't help were you
worried you're gonna be on a
ventilator and [ __ ] no i wasn't worried
about that it was just like mentally i
was just like
going crazy because i'm like okay you
have no get you have no engagement of
when you're
going to get better well we could have
looked it up or you called me
10 to 14 days daddy that's science you
called that i've been doing that science
i i i told you 19.
i told you that but i had i had friends
with doctors he's 60.
yeah don't call brian i'm calling me
dude here now here's what
i know i'm getting some papers dude it
made my endurance better when i got out
of this
i don't have anything like my endurance
for a day my energy's still
trash is it are you sleepy right now am
i sleeping right now yeah
yeah you don't use any cats i'm drunk
right now i'm drunk right now my girls
my girls
uh lungs have never been the same really
i'm honest
hey come on but my lungs are better than
they were before i feel really
how would you know because i took
because you don't run
or do nothing how did you know you went
on a bike ride earlier and i went on a
bike ride
yeah that's a beach cruise hey i got
good and i got a good win dude
yeah yeah i do you can't go right down
the pier and tell me you're
[ __ ] well here's the thing daddy hit
daddy's lungs and what happened with me
i was coughing and i couldn't sleep and
then my doctor friend goes
hold your breath and count to uh count
to twenty and i did and he goes you're
fine
because i thought i was gonna die and
then i got prescribed the old steroids
oh yeah and i and i took that my son has
that yeah and i take coffee
yeah i was good [ __ ] that's nice you do
what i'll steal some puffs from i'm like
one two
one for me of those steroids yeah yeah
it really opens up your lungs
really all right that's great i think i
might i think i might have to get it
dude it's remix friday you don't need it
no you don't i think i
you don't have a cough bro don't get
crazy yeah he feels like
he feels heavy why don't hate on him
yeah i told you sometimes when i
whenever i take a like a deep breath
like there's still a little tightness
you know you should do smoke cigarettes
oh there you go smoke cigarettes
here's what didn't help me well i was
fine and then a friend of mine i know is
very smart i'll tell you who he is after
this
very smart guy bit of a scientist and
he's
got so many smart friends is he a
scientist uh yeah
okay you said because you don't know
what i don't know what i'm talking about
when i tell you you'll be like oh
smart like smart smart okay well you
can't just yeah and he goes um
and he follows all the [ __ ] he can
read all the science [ __ ]
and he was like i think it's i think
it's very serious and i think it's
you know he wasn't going anywhere his
wife wasn't going anywhere and i'm like
and then he said and then he hits me
with this i said i feel fine i mean i
feel
sick low-grade shitty for now and he
says no i know
i would just i personally would just
like to see what it's actually doing to
your brain your lungs
and your heart that's why i'd like to
see that because we're seeing more and
more
uh of long-term i'm like hey dude you
know what you know how about this
do you know what i told him what oh the
long term what what long term
it's been out a year dude yeah so save
that [ __ ]
say that when i was sick though correct
yeah even earlier in the game yeah so
long term
what evidence do you have for long-term
effects that's a good point there's none
didn't think of that no it's it's you
it's them
pandering the fear thing well we don't
know how it's gonna affect you long term
right because what if yeah well you
don't know if it's gonna be good or bad
right we have no evidence and by the way
even if you are a long-hauler you
eventually
get better they say like most people get
what do you mean
10 to 14 days daddy sure called me you'd
been right
so you were you were how long has it
been uh [ __ ] that was i think it was
when was the 11th was that a monday so
you've been
you've been you've got the two weeks
under your belt now daddy runs a tight
ship here because i said
i said i can't have you back into give
me a negative test mm-hmm gotta have a
negative test
threw it in now now you still don't have
your taste and smell
no man that's gonna be gone for a hot
day so technically you're still dealing
with the ramifications
yeah that's what i'm saying i think it
might be
it's very interesting i have a good nose
but i have to say i think i might have
changed my taste for wine i said that
before
i i just am not that into wine anymore
because cause of cove i believe that
because you can't taste it for a while
coffee and wine tasted
i mean smelled horrible yeah for a while
after
and now now i'm back well now and jay
says i'm full of [ __ ] he's like you've
always liked this bitter
stuff because like with i have to have
like really strong
whiskey i have to have really strong
coffee yeah i can eat really spicy stuff
now
oh you can now that's what i say you
always like dark roast yeah jay's like
what you've always been like
no it's cold he's like shut up i don't
know as you get older sometimes when you
do more of that stuff my palate
yeah and your power i'm fine i can't
believe you tried to work out on well
while i haven't covered stupid what i do
i was bike riding 40 miles every day
well i set my ass i'm just now fired for
that
i'll trip it you just you sh dude you
shut it down to the fact that
you wouldn't even text us back no he
shut down even his tent
chat with me him and mark shut it down
yeah dude
i wouldn't even respond to that i was
like i wouldn't do a [ __ ]
i just watched king of the hill yeah
what else did that was
yeah what else all right um
i watched that scary movie jen what'd i
tell you man
good huh good movie you got to see it
you ever seen it no anyone else seen it
what just you and i you guys [ __ ]
suck man you still haven't watched gin
not yet and i thought you were into
scary movies oh no
he spilled uh stevia all over his
[ __ ] computer
ain't no sugar or anything in that so
you're good suck on it chin
yup suck the suck it get you get your
face suck the keyboard dude get your
face in there
get your face down the door yeah deep
throw that keyboard dude there you go
don't listen to them
you guys i thought you and steve are on
a scary movie actually we're gonna and
then we started watching love island
because the new season came out
not feeling it so far no i'm off love
island i watched too hot to handle
what's that oh yeah that's a big one now
have you not seen that is it something
is it a reality show
yeah i'm way too old but i just my girl
watched it so i'm just like
i'll watch it and it's ch i watched the
brazilian one
you you dude i'm telling you you gotta
watch you gotta watch love island uh
season five what's that about season
five
it's like uh it's a dating show it's a
dating show but they all live in a house
and then they'll bring in like a new
like bombshell every now and then just
to mix it up and then they got a
if if you don't meet with a partner like
they don't pick you you get off the
island
wow they'd be [ __ ] too dude there's a
new one coming up
i'm not into the new ones good looking
people huh good luck no a new show
yeah uh tyson fury's brother's on it
handsome devil handsome kitchen
you haven't seen him bring him up let me
see him there's six foot six the big guy
no that's it no six price six
four he can box too yeah i mean he only
has like six fights but yeah
thomas tommy stunned super stud
oh jesus yeah and he's still with this
girl from the show
yep good for him that's a handsome [ __ ]
man that's right
you're very stupid handsome jesus christ
and they're weird so and he can beat you
up so uh
tyson so he has him and so
him and thai sphere have the same dad
but they have different moms oh okay
he's got some tents and apparently his
mom was better looking
by the way tyson's in his 20s i believe
this kid is a little this kid is
super wide is that his way is that his
girl right there
yeah she was on the right molly mae and
she she's a dimension
dude yeah she did she was they were
great on the show they were like the
couple on the show they won
right okay no they did not win the black
girl ambrose
love amber bring them up they're all
good looking they're so good looking
right the whole show's just feeling
pretty big
he's got blue eyes too what the [ __ ] is
going on and he's a good guy
like on the show he tells you he's a
good guy yeah he's a great guy
good boxer too yeah i didn't want i
didn't see i respect that he can box
did anybody watch the uh opening
ceremony of the olympics
i didn't dude you want to talk about
depressing
nobody because tokyo like has like this
legit like
covet problem like they're shutting down
like it's spreading so nobody was there
nobody's in the crowd the imagine
working your entire life to get the
olympics and you get there during a cove
at time
everybody's a mask so you can't see
english
any nothing not smiling laughing
everyone's a mess
all countries are a mess so lame
the ratings can't be good dude this is
the first time for skateboarding it's
like a 20 billion dollar bust
so far oh nobody's watching it like
women's soccer team got
like they lost for the first time yeah
yeah that's where
oh we dominated world cup champions you
think they got them they they
they got to mix up the they can't mix it
up like make it a little more hip i
guess
i don't know i don't know what you do i
wonder if they was just saying
they added skateboarding to it yeah i
don't know if that's going to do it my
man
they got a lot of pushback for the
kneeling stuff
so i wanted sometimes sometimes oh they
banned that so you
so now like it is it's against the rules
for you to like kneel during the
national anthem or the award ceremony
they're gonna give you a certain you can
do it a certain time but not during
uh when you get an award wow yeah the
the female soccer team kneeled before
the uh for the national anthem didn't
they oh
yeah they kneeled for the national
anthem and then they got they got their
ass out
i found them we just recently i got a
problem with it that's what they got
they got knocked off
who's not even a good team is what i've
heard well i'm glad they lost me
i'm glad they're allowed sweden yeah i
know a lot of people who are rooting
against them for that like like
like me yeah me too and then they won't
be like oh we deserve bigger pay
it's like well hey it's the market value
and then if you didn't think people like
you before
now you're gonna kneel against the flag
good luck and you're gonna lose
and good and now good luck in sponsors
jump on board who are gonna pay you what
you think you're worth right so they're
all going to be out if the marketplace
says you're worth something we're not
going to pay you just because you're
women or just because it's the times
are you worth it do you get butts in the
states it's a business it's a business
it's a business so i i can't stand that
idea of like
we have to get paid as much as who well
they wanted more than the men's because
they're like we're better but then
the way it works is there's a lion's
share so you know in that men's you have
brazil and you know england and they're
making the majority of the money but it
trickles down
so all the teams get paid when the
women's only
the american team you know makes any
amount of money
it's not a lot we live in the
marketplace yeah 100 i mean you know
so it's just how it works it's amazing
it's like wnba like yo
she has paid as much as kyrie irving
that's hilarious it's like
nobody's paying like you haven't you hey
you've
never sold out again nobody watches you
you guys no if that
you get paid that if if people were
watching right and that's not
that's not a those just like the
marketplace it's your problem it's
called the market that's the business
yeah
but also like i i you you have a right
to kneel um
to the flag i i i love america because
you actually have a right to burn the
flag if you want
it but i also have a right to protest
that i also have a right to turn my back
on you
so you know it's fine yeah i just want
to support it no you don't
i i personally find it offensive i think
it's i think it's the greatest country
still the greatest country in the world
in terms of freedoms
and and all those things we have our
problems uh but my god we're getting
better and better
and there are a lot of countries you
could choose to go to including in
europe
where you would not have the same
freedoms so yeah
you know but that's a whole different
thing there's a whole goddamn yeah well
we were talking about anybody who's
gonna watch it though i i don't think
anybody's watching just the olympics in
general
do you i see when they get to the
sprints and stuff that's what usually
gets
sprints in gymnastics gymnastics yeah i
was going to say gymnastics usually
outside that though
you want to do the cross like the weird
shooting
what is that i don't know what it's
so no not the skeet shooting chin ski
shooting no it's cross cut that's lame
too this one what is it called
teleshooting or something like that oh i
know what's called a waste of time yeah
i know it's called i don't care i know
what it's called
i know it's called nobody's going to
watch this first of all i don't give a
[ __ ] about um
cross-country skiing and i know you got
to be in shape i don't care
i would never watch well you better be
in shape to be in the olympia yeah okay
aren't you a skier no i mean i can ski
but no
oh no i'm a skier the way i play tennis
i mean you know
and then then the the men's basketball
team like our best players aren't
playing because they're short of season
you have kim duran on the team but
outside that
number of superstars on the team and the
other thing is is the other country is
getting better like they lost to nigeria
but the teams are just like because it's
such a global sport like teams are
getting better
oh yeah oh yeah so they lost they're
like yeah they're pretty [ __ ] good
got some good athletes in nigeria
now if we loaded up our a team we would
dump all over them
but our guys aren't going yeah yeah some
guys just don't know like
why why aren't they going shorter season
you know
some of them don't want to represent
america or whatever um who knows
when did when did america become such a
piece of [ __ ] country to these people
who are younger who grew up in a much
better uh
and more equitable world than i did and
way more it's not cool to say that
it's amazing yeah it's amazing how we
were talking about this how i feel like
the older we get the more
we are the counter revolutionaries and
the younger people
you can't say what you don't mean
meaning you can't joke you can't say
what you think because you'll get fired
right away or cancelled right away well
did you see the guy
do you see the guy he was he was on the
committee for the olympics he's uh
he's from tokyo he's on the commission
of it yeah dude they they
fired him from the committee oh i know
for a joke he told
me special in 1994 20 years ago
and it was a it was an allusion to the
holocaust
and it was it was literally like a joke
yeah it was i
read the whole thing it was he's a he
was actually a funny sketch and it
wasn't a bad it was what it was
and he got fired seriously
in 1990 so they are drumming up your
your past
and deciding i guess that this guy's a
racist or whatever he is
and because he did a joke that a bunch
of people did he's
a [ __ ] japanese guy he's a japanese
guy huh
yeah kentucky yeah let's play holocaust
but it was just a [ __ ] just a joke he
didn't he got fired let me try that
brian many many years later
how are you too big you're too big your
hip's not too flexible yeah
no those thoughts that's right but yeah
isn't that amazing and i i just when
they when is this insanity
well you know shane gillis was on rogan
did you see him take a big swing and a
miss
no oh do you never seen this i saw it it
dude it's so funny so rowan's like so
tell us like how the senate stuff came
about
he's doing it right and he's going
through it and rowan's like uh-huh
uh-huh
and he goes yeah and then lauren you
know lauren uh michael's brought me into
his office
he's like we're gonna have to let you go
man and he and then uh
the camera's just on shane gillis and he
goes yeah someone told me that
i was like oh that's fine i told him
i'll just go on joe rogan
crickets i'm talking crickets and he and
he says he goes i'll just go on joe
rogan he leaks it rogers
and he goes no not funny orangus
okay dude it has to be the most awkward
moment
in jre joe help him out
dude it was like but the camera's not in
joe so it's like was joe just not paying
attention or
but i think joe was just like not buying
it like this isn't a real he was just
listening
or yeah he was like this and then jane
goes
no swinging him in
damn and shane gillis is a monster like
he's a great have you seen his stuff
no i hear he's gross dude he's an insane
great things about him yeah he's an
insane comment
great i'm so glad he's doing his own
sketch show now on on youtube and
it's funny oh it's so funny it's so
funny
you haven't seen that i love hearing
that the you haven't seen it's been on
trump of speed dating
no oh yeah really it's
so [ __ ] good he's he's apparently the
real deal man yeah
yeah there's a reason why you know a
solid guy who's gonna hire him good
he's a beast and and and what redemption
i'll do my
own sketch show yep yeah you know yeah
it's not saturday live but yeah i don't
know if saturday night live it's
certainly not what it used to be
no it's definitely no it's definitely
not what you what is what it is
better to have your own show on youtube
if it's your own show
sketch show we're all talking
financially name one person on saturday
night live
just name one punky johnson pete
davidson not anymore no
he's still on there he hasn't landed yet
pete davidson all right yeah i don't
know from saturday night
you know him from the other stuff pete
yeah i know from center life
what other stuff yeah the point is we
don't talk about saturday night live the
way we used to do
we don't talk about well but you don't
talk about any tv like that yeah like
there's no show compared to seinfeld
better to have your own [ __ ] sketch
show on youtube
i disagree we're all talking about it no
no no we're talking about because i
brought up shane gilson no
that's not true i've heard i've had a
lot of people say it's a great show and
they talk about no that's a great show
is it bigger than saturday now listen
for him it's a better idea i think
for him it's it's redemption 100
i see what you're saying oh yeah i don't
i don't and listen i love shane gillis i
know we're all about this
you know you think being on snl and
being the sex is a much bigger deal than
having your own show
seventh cast member on snl would be what
he's an actual casper
what sell tickets not really dude i know
people who
i'm telling i also know people yeah
listen i'm not saying that he's gonna
sell tickets
you're crazy if you think doing a a skit
out of your
house is a bigger deal than be on
saturday night live in some ways i think
it is he has full creative control
which is great financially it's not even
close i don't they don't make that much
money
who does it people honest no neither
needed a sketch once a month on youtube
bubba
that may be true but and he's he's like
in millions of views so we got to calm
down a little i know we're like
anti-establishment and stuff like that
science life is a
big deal it's a big deal yeah i mean it
still does a lot for people
yeah you know i mean i mean punky
johnson just got her own tv show well
look at pete davidson
look at look at look at look at [ __ ]
uh i mean all the people
uh keaney and ivory wings there's just a
lot of guys there are a lot of elements
there are a lot of people that have gone
through that machine a lot who are not
who are
but that doesn't mean it's not good yeah
there's a lot that blew the [ __ ]
i don't know i see there are people yeah
dude same thing man i i
no it's not it's not as good but what tv
is though
compared to back in the day like there's
so many outlets now yeah
but i don't think we can sit here and be
like no he's better off doing out of his
house than being on saturday
live well i mean hopefully hopefully it
gets bigger to the point where he's
making millions of dollars off that but
currently right now people like that are
just funny and they find their way
uh just stuck with it he just stayed
what else would he do though
yeah was he gonna quit yeah i mean no he
just does stand up and
but he was funny on there he was like
well he's like
when people get canceled he's like
they're usually like famous already he's
like
i wasn't even famous he made him he was
like i was just getting started and then
he canceled me
yeah he's like so it's a weird position
to be in is it because like you know
like
[ __ ] someone gets canceled they
usually find they have money they can do
other stuff he's like dude i
don't have [ __ ] i was broken i carry
that yeah
yeah yeah it's not his is different he's
very well liked though
yeah people everyone loves it yeah yeah
great great great comedian he's in that
new york crew right yeah yeah
you talk to anyone he's like the next
big thing out of there [ __ ] yeah
cause those guys doing five six sets a
night man
you know it's it's great and it's just a
great community that holds you
accountable
we were on the jfl new faces together
and he did a bit about
uh i i i don't think
white people love country music no he
did a special olympics bit
which like no one thought like because
it's new faces you know you're coming
out there with like your
you know your best stuff and shane
gillis just rolled out there
he said i'm gonna close with this
[ __ ] boom monster
oh dude lit the crowd up yeah and he was
the last comic to go on
he was yeah we were on the same lineup i
think that's what sounded like salt
uh i think so that's where they think so
and then when he auditions
live he said he just did stand up like
that's how he got there
yeah yeah he just really that that
audition process
i've talked to people from amy poehler
to whoever
it it was it used to be such a nightmare
they would make you
like lauren michaels had this whole
philosophy of making you wait they still
do yeah he went through all that six
hours in the in the hallway
just different characters five different
characters scenes
all kinds of [ __ ] yeah chemistry reads
with each other all kinds of stuff even
eddie murphy would say how crazy
like uh he was how crazy it was yeah 19
years old he said he said all they said
he walked in
and all they said was make me laugh and
then he was like
okay here we go yeah shane said he was
on the main stage
and there's like the riders there's a
camera then lauren michaels
and he said the agent said now you're
gonna do your stand up and nobody's
going to laugh
so just power through it don't worry
about them laughing and you say start
off with a joke and then i started
laughing he's like i thought they
weren't supposed to laugh
so he said when they started laughing
he's like oh [ __ ] i got this yeah yeah
that's amazing i've done i used to
audition for cbs when les moonves
was kind of the emperor there and could
do no wrong he's like one of the
greatest
like studio heads ever and you would
walk into that room and i probably
auditioned for them
i don't think it's an exaggeration to
say 12
13 14 times where you where i test it
where it's like
you go through five auditions it's
finally the test
it's the network test just audition for
the studio then they go to the network
and now they decide who's going to get
the part
got one one time it worked out um but uh
but you would go in there man and you'd
be doing the scene and doing like your
thing and everything
and i'm telling you man it would they
would make it a point not to laugh
it was i think it was les moon says he
would just he would just
stare at you and dude it would be
[ __ ] crickets
in this in this soundproof studio and
you just you wanted the parts so bad
because you just needed to just work you
didn't want to go through another year
of nowhere
you got one part of it and then you'd go
and sit down and then they would they
would do this
they would come back out and they'd go
brennan thanks so much you can leave
you can leave thanks uh can you come
back in and read within yourself
have a good one i guess that's the way
that is or sometimes nobody get called
in
and you just see them all walk out and
they wouldn't look at you
there's no way to treat people yeah why
do they why do they do that no it's not
it's how i lived for a good 20 years
so why be [ __ ]
to the point where i quit to the point
where i i remember i said to patty
jenkins i go
i quit acting i [ __ ] quit i'm doing
just stand up and i had a conversation
with rogan and then the gold works came
around
jesus i i've got that i got yeah that
was seven years ago
i mean yeah i was like yeah dude that's
how long
four years ago i was like i've done this
for 20 years yeah done
yeah and then talking about uh
uh oh rogan or he said people are like
because
he only he's that podcast that got him
canceled he's like
it was the only time we ever had video
for a podcast
and he was like my friends and family
like man i bet they had to dig deep to
get that he was no not really
he was like i said that in like the
first two minutes and he's like if that
didn't get me there's so much more [ __ ]
out there
they thought that was offensive of
course there's so much more [ __ ] you
know you get if you get in trouble for
for which i have for what you said i
mean we're all [ __ ]
what is this what are we doing yeah like
again
again you used to be able to say what
you don't mean
and it was like i was joking or it was
the context no
now to your point if shane gillis wants
to keep talking like that and freely
then yeah saturday life's not a good
place for him right because then that
all goes you're gonna have to walk a
tight line
yeah to please the executives and you
can't be if you want to go loosey goosey
you can't do that well tim dillon is
just loosey-goosey funny
and sometimes he's gonna be outrageous
and i want con i want a world where
comics can do that
yeah you know not worry about not being
able to pay their bills
yeah tim's like the last like outlaw
right he will
fire off off the hip he's hilarious that
way that's what got him there
dressing up like a woman and freaking
out like a mess oh
we need that we need more of that that's
why when bill burke goes off
and crazy and i was like man you know
what's weird too is
you know bill's pretty hollywood yeah
bill's i mean he's the
you know not that hollywood's nowhere
near what it used to be but bill's
pretty hollywood oh he's hot he's in
star wars
he's in a movie like legit big movies
he's like he's pretty hollywood still
speaking for him to fire off yeah bill's
a real one
yeah but but you can't allow there's not
many guys that can hollywood to change
that no
i had a conversation with some pretty
big directors on
just how the business uh like big big
people in the business i was i was at a
dinner and i take it easy yeah but it
was no they were
just they were just like dealing with
the tentpole movie like producers and
those
guys and i was listening to them uh
about the new considerations
that come into play now as you were back
in the day
yeah like just [ __ ] twitter like
five fifteen-year-olds who are like
[ __ ] we don't that did that and
they don't want to deal with it that's
why these
big actors you don't see them on
podcasts anymore you don't really see
them
doing an interview or anything it is
it's all vanilla [ __ ]
like it's not the same bad for art
bad for culture bad for us yeah [ __ ] off
are you being attacked from comics have
to do pick up two comics that's the job
of a comic
so so did uh were they like yeah we quit
or they're just gonna power through it
or
they all are a little bit bitter
or a little bit like exhausted yeah like
you know what it is it's like um there's
there's there there's no advantage to
being
well known and having a high profile
movie it's just
it's it's you're so open to taking
all the blame not just on your movie
failing
but if you didn't make the right choices
with your movie
if you didn't put the right categories
of people in there
you don't have a trans representative
and things like that you hear about
well even the guy who created friends
was like yeah we messed up
he's like if i could do it again i
should have uh booked like casted more
of a diverse
cast it's like or not like what's he
talking about yeah but it's like
i know i know you're trying to save face
right now because friends was all white
people
but it's like or not dude like that show
crushed yeah but yeah seinfeld too what
are we talking about yeah
i mean it is what it is there was a
chemistry the other thing is that
sometimes it's just the chemistry
that works but also i hate to tell you
they're what were that
what was it five white friends yeah man
there's a lot of
five white friends
also a lot of white people that'll watch
that like to the two to 30 40 million
people at all
but all ethnicities would watch that but
why does it have to be a race thing they
were just five really funny friends and
that's the show
friends and how about the writers on
that who are geniuses
yeah and and how their actors like
jennifer anderson would go into the
writers room after they would do the
reading
they would go to the writers room and
jennifer anderson etc would be
would be in there and very few actors do
this
part of the reason that that show was so
good is those actors would go into the
writer's room
and sit with them and work their
characters out and say i don't think my
character
there's joey and the one with the other
white guy chandler challenge
so chandler i guess he was like he
started drinking heavily and doing drugs
because
he was like the comedy relief like you'd
always have like these jokes
and he said he felt so much pressure if
the jokes didn't hit yep
he felt so much pressure yep damn he
talks about that
yeah like very kind of insecure yeah
drugs were you a big fan of that show
i i never really watched much of it but
it's a very good show
seinfeld is a great show it's great i
never watched much of the simpsons south
park i never watched a lot of but
they're all great shows yeah every time
i watch michael
i mean i thought third rock was a great
show tina fey is a [ __ ] badass
the way she can write well that whole
cast was a beast oh my god
with tracy morgan i auditioned for some
more gambino's on there
he wasn't he on there no he was a writer
yeah that's right and
tina fey convinced him this rap you know
that yeah they they call me and they go
there's an amazing part in the show tina
fey show third rock
and it and it was alec baldwin's part
which i didn't know of course and i'm
i worked so hard in that part it worked
and then i didn't get it i didn't get it
i wonder why you're gonna get
bald yeah i think it's a different show
yeah no you're thinking thirty rock not
thirty
i'm sorry guys yeah yeah that's the run
from the sun third rock was a great show
actually that was a great show that was
back in [ __ ] the 90s
yeah that was around the same time i was
blossoming and [ __ ] and then what was
the other one that the nerd like
super nerdy uh big bang was it big bang
theory
yeah oh yeah big bang is a big every
game
who's the indian guy on it and um
it was this movie you know it's that
movie about a talking dog i don't want
to talk about it and um
and and when was this i i i
what
when i went to china remember when i
went to beijing that was that movie yeah
covered in psoriasis covered in
psoriasis
that guy right there uh canal yeah he is
a [ __ ] he's a great guy
um they make so much money by the way
they make yeah they're so ready
but he is such a good actor the
[ __ ] is such a good actor
like like if you see the the work he
puts into it just wakes up and goes to
it he knew the movie wasn't gonna be a
big hit and that [ __ ] was
so good he was so good in it like er
like you could see
the i don't know what i was talking a
fake dog and [ __ ] oh dude he he you you
cast that guy in a movie
again his the success is not an accident
he's always going to be successful yeah
tall bird with him yeah she was missing
it's the heels look at this he's
actually from india and she's miss india
i think oh wow yeah
yeah he's an amazing guy i love that
dude i spent most of my time with him
yeah we're watching
my girl re-watching game of thrones you
they got so
paid nobody from the that show does
anything now
they're just like we're good yeah they
don't they make some real money
game of thrones yeah oh my god yes oh
they paid pay
paid yeah well you're there that's a
that's a six years of your life where
you're just gone the whole time in
northern ireland somewhere longer than
that
were they filmed that was eight years
eight years just dressing up with yeah
they filmed all over europe
scotland all over you got to know the
creators of that right a little bit yeah
mm-hmm but at the time i didn't watch it
[ __ ] oh right
my whole bit was uh when someone talked
about gamer thrones up like there's
dragons in it right they're like yeah
like grown man
i remember that now i'm obsessed with it
it was such a shame i missed the
opportunity to talk
he was on on a private jet with these
[ __ ] devices
yeah i thought they were writers for
always sunny and i go you guys write for
always sunday i was like the new season
they're like what
like no i was like what do you do game
of thrones was like lame
and then just didn't talk and i i said
did you ask him questions you're like
nah dragons i was like oh god i was so
smart those people how many seasons does
that show eight
but they get so into the books so you
know they're yeah fire and ice or
something
if they were on script for like
the first five seasons like but five and
a half after five and a half they go off
script and they do it themselves
and it's not as good oh really they get
a lot
but the first five are [ __ ] fire i
don't mind six the network was probably
like we want more seasons
the red wedding insane
dude she sees the chain mail under his
thing she's all [ __ ]
no i'm not it's better the second time
i'm gonna start wearing chain mail and
getting into knife fights
is that what you're gonna do i don't
give a [ __ ] did you why would you do you
you only watch
you think you didn't get into any shows
really just you know me dog
you had nothing to do i know you've not
you've had i literally had
and i thought about it too i literally
had every opportunity
to watch to get into something did you
see game of thrones have you ever seen
it no i've never seen it
that is like my life story you haven't
never seen anything favorite moment
in game of thrones when you think again
is there an image or a scene that comes
to mind
winter is coming i know that part that
part's [ __ ] great that's all i know
this there's so many one minus
like when i realized it was a great show
when when uh the mother of dragons
uh whatever her name is that remember
that the uh
um the guy who had the legion of
soldiers that would do anything where he
cuts the guy's nipple off and he doesn't
oh it's when they're speaking the
the native tongue and she doesn't and
she doesn't he's trying to hold that
dragon the baby dragon
and she says that's a dragon and he is
not used to being take
that he's not born to take orders from a
tyrant like you
and she just goes she says that says
that yeah and that thing just goes
because she's trying to hold on and i
was like and she did gives him the
command and just goes
out of all this all the scenes
i want a pet dragon man a baby one
called my baby dragon scene was awful
dude you know they commented there's so
many good things please don't do that
they come in the man dragon it's and
it's never caught on
no it's caught on people how's your
merch go
i haven't made any merch yet but if you
guys guys thanks for the overwhelming
request for
merch man dragon merch
it's common guys guys it's coming you
know when something doesn't work and you
keep running that play he's just that's
probably
[ __ ] dude i never try i never get in
a car
on the street where i'm not inundated
with man dragon and [ __ ] mandarin
thanks a lot you guys appreciate it give
us one i'm like
please they're like oh what the [ __ ]
that's amazing
it just doesn't i i'm saying i i agree
but i'm saying
the fans freak out when i say man dragon
i just wish it worked
it does dude stop f i stop
poo pooing my nickname that was given to
me by the people it's not cool they're
not going to be happy
i can't believe about all the scenes
and he's like no and she said [ __ ] do
it and then the
dragon
for
is real languages no it's made up
that's somebody's kid sometimes you have
a kid who's into that
gosh oh is this it
oh my god watch this scene [ __ ] this is
your scene it's seven minutes long i
know that's fortunate
very important how far is it hbo calm
down
hold on i'll keep going no no there was
it there it was here
oh no sherry no go back go back go back
go back go back
here she takes their army what's up with
that blondie though this
i want stevie to watch this so bad he's
never seen game of thrones no he can't
stand
uh dragons accents
that's just look at this guy from boston
this guy's been talking [ __ ] about her
the whole time calling her like a [ __ ]
and stuff
and the guy doesn't know she can
understand what he's saying
see she's like [ __ ] and stuff because
they're all slaves that arm is also
you don't [ __ ] around you guys hey that
is a pretty dope scene yeah it's a
[ __ ] joke
that was so off he's like remember she's
like that dragon
does not like masters and then the drag
was all blue
and then he was like you mean
you know the jaws on i don't remember it
like that
my god
and he was just holding it like this i
got the gist of it though brian i got to
just
[ __ ] yeah it'll get you right like the
from the jungle it looks dope though
yeah thanks for calling me the man yes
oh we just watched we just watched that
that's pretty crazy she has some tits on
her she has the mommy
naked in there oh dude there's so much
nudity in it
dudes gals dragons hey dude white walker
i can't
are you part do you live in 2020 no i
know dude
you've got to be a little bit part of
the zeitgeist a little bit i know you're
in skateboarding and
and and the crowmags etc but can you
do you think you could get a little with
the times
he's an iphone 3. is there any way
you're an iphone 3. chappelle still
plays playstation 1.
you know there's a playstation 5 dude
he's like damn really when that come out
yo
[ __ ] dude [ __ ] is right i know i'll give
it a chance
i'm gonna work on it so so you don't
have any of the tv under your belt
none no no tv underwear so would you
play video games
no not even that no so you i'm not mad
at that you're in the music
yeah and then you're into skateboarding
uh-huh um
comedy okay you journal journal
you dropped how's the german once you've
been in here oh bro
i did not touch my journal at all i mean
what would you write about bro
i couldn't
when you was playing the joker and gone
crazy in your journal that would be cool
what do you say holy descendants of
madness wait what about heath ledges
ledger played the joker in dark knight
right yeah and he
isolated himself in a hotel room for
like two weeks and did nothing but
journal
and you can progressively see him slowly
go crazy yeah yeah he received away so i
don't suggest that you ever see that
scene in the shining
where jack nicholson's writing he's a
writer
writing okay please get this scene we're
going to watch it
bring it up because i want to make sure
to watch it we can't show any of this by
the way i know
like this and then she's like he's
riding we can't show this and she would
come down i know you can show this you
can see him
slowly start to go crazy because she
comes down she goes i want to see if you
wanted some food and he goes
um i'm writing so kindly get the [ __ ]
out
you know and she's like jesus and then
blah blah blah blah blah
and then you she sees what he's been
writing the whole time the whole time
go ahead and go ahead it's basically is
it all played
no whatever i'll work all work hey your
[ __ ] typewriter sound effects pretty
damn good yup
makes jack a dumb yeah
[Music]
he's [ __ ] great took place in uh
colorado
that's right it did yeah the shining
yeah
stephen king wrote this [ __ ] book
doesn't remember writing it either
yep staying stanley oh this is the
[ __ ] also where dumb and dumber was
that
this dumb idiot
[Music]
[Laughter]
figured out he's going [ __ ] crazy
sweet killer boots man you know when
they shot this they actually did this to
her they made her really they were so
mean to her
get a lot written today okay i
understand
do you know the story around the movie
you know he goes crazy and tries to kill
him
oh [ __ ] yeah he's like possessed let's
just
wendy let me explain something to you
whenever you come in here and interrupt
me you're breaking my concentration
you're distracting me and it will then
take me time to get back to where i was
understand such a psycho don't hear me
typing with
the [ __ ] you hear me doing in here when
i'm in here that means that i am working
that means don't come in preach why
don't you start right now
and get the [ __ ] out of here god damn so
[ __ ] scary
apparently or just an [ __ ] yeah
apparently with the actress
they were really mean to her the whole
time on set yeah because they wanted to
stay in character no
but they were barely slapped craft
services no i don't think so
yeah no that's a that's a rumor that's
what brian said
it's a rumor have you seen that movie no
okay so this scene really sucks
yeah i gotta make a list of some some
movies together make a list make a list
and i'll watch them all promise i will
start with game of thrones
it's eight seasons and then go game of
thrones it's still working but you'll
love it dude it's so good
what else you gonna do i know right hey
i tried to start that i tried to start
that yellowstone one
brother [ __ ] me up when he killed the
horse like in the first yeah
10 seconds so you stopped watching yeah
yeah i was like
yeah i haven't watched it is that worth
getting that wasn't why i stopped
watching it
come on it should that first episode is
an hour and 32 minutes
you have nothing to do dude also that's
that's [ __ ] what are the movies
the king of the hills sweater movies hey
king of the hill is funny as [ __ ]
not for me i ain't seen it i have
trouble with the animation
cartoony stuff what the only one i can
[ __ ] with is rick and morty
i ain't seen it i ain't seen it
they get if i watch kingpin it's a very
old movie
but how funny is uh feel very solid
he's so still murray is one of the
greats
he's [ __ ] one of the greats so that's
what he's doing he is great
harrison though he's woody's great too i
didn't realize randy quade and dennis
played with
brothers yep oh yeah same last name yeah
there
oh okay no but they are they that's true
they're they seem like good guys don't
look like brothers
it looks so different so different dude
if you're sensitive to that horse being
shot
i wasn't susan game
when that dude once when he he's with
the red lady yeah and she convinced him
to kill his daughter and he'll become
king yeah
and he sets his daughter on fire she's
like daddy what are you doing daddy no
yeah and the mom like you commit suicide
after that
that's good stuff that seems so stunning
what's up with peter dinklage he's in it
right right
now he's amazing he's the best character
peter i i knew back in the day he's so
good
oh you know that guy yeah great most
famous small man
of all time his parents raised him like
there was never a mention
it was like apparently he was raised
like basically to be and they were like
you're basically same size as everybody
else
no excuses go about your business really
yes
and you always had an amazing sense of
humor wow that's amazing always [ __ ]
he's the best character in that for sure
yeah yeah
yeah he's the best character and they're
coming out with the spin-off
but uh the original writers aren't
reading that
yeah it's based off of the storyline
that george rr martin wrote though
she could be good george r martin that's
the
original so they want him to redo season
eight and finish writing season a but
he's like older and has no
no interest well he's writing the book
still he doesn't have an interest in
going back and redoing the show yeah
zero yeah got it because the rumor is
that uh
cersei's is supposed to get with the
head uh white walker
that's how it's supposed to be look at
you you look at you this into grandma's
thrones after poo pooing it for five
[ __ ] years i know what like i didn't
watch anything just being insulting
about it
i went dragons yeah just like all of
that on rogan all the time you guys
tried to convince me
yeah but there's dragons now you're now
you're into the [ __ ] apparently
the the sequel because the guy then his
wife
his wife has a name
and another thing about the sequel and
the guy who wrote it his daughter went
to school private school and
it's weird man you just don't learn the
language
that's when it's so crazy it's two
made-up languages they have more than
that
there are more but i think the one that
people tend to learn is dothraki because
there's
yeah i mean jesus christ the og bunny
ranch
yeah yeah but every like little kingdom
had their own bunny ranch was sick
yeah of course i don't know if it's
really like that yeah well you know
the truth is in those in those times
when you came into a [ __ ]
city you basically enslaved all the
women and children
and killed all the men so hey what up
peter dinklage what's going on
he's so good he'd be getting the girls
in him yeah that's his favorite thing to
do
oh really that's his favorite thing to
do damn
yeah they're um
yeah they're all gorgeous yeah but no
you don't see all of them just got paid
i'm like nah we're good
work is that do you think that's what it
is because i have a different thought on
that they get paid
no no but i have a different thought on
why they're not working type of
work yeah a lot of times well the one
girl the red the redhead
uh yeah sophie turner uh somebody's a
fan over there uh sophie turner
she she did the right honor she did the
rogue movie yeah she tried
she tried that action movie and see that
the problem is
what i would do with those she was the
next that's what i'm saying she did that
marvel x-men
yeah she was on a new movie fairly
recently that
was launched on i think apple tv i would
resist all that
you have to be really careful of choices
you make after that they try to push you
into these other things and make you
something you're not
i don't know well but maybe she doesn't
be known as just the game of thrones
girl
right but there's i think there's a
there's a strategic way to do it and
sometimes when they
like so charlie hunman remember him who
did uh
yeah and he was he was the guy there
i've seen that have we watched
about that yep and he smartly they they
wanted him to be
the next he they wanted to be 50 shades
of gray i think
and he said no no no no he said yes and
there's such an
outrage of him being casted as that he
stepped down there was another movie
where he had to talk with his girlfriend
they turn it down remember
and he tried to be very careful and then
he did uh another movie that was
this big action movie and that didn't go
well and
it's tough no matter what it's tough
it's tough
all right jim what do you got first all
righty
let's take a little break with the boys
cause man times are tough it can be
tough man and you're worried about your
student loan payments
it doesn't make things easier that's why
my friends at earnest can help you out
that's right say goodbye to the
stressful student loan payments
and take charge of your future with the
team at
earnest earnest offers low rate student
loan refinancing
you can check your rate risk free in
just two minutes with earnest
you get flexible payments you can pick
your loan term
by refinancing can reduce your loan
terms save money
or combine multiple loans into one
simple monthly payment
if you have questions you can talk to
real human at the earnest team to help
you out man
earnest is offering you guys the firing
kid watchers and listeners
hundred dollar cash bonus refinance your
student debt
at earnest.com fighter terms conditions
apply
ernest is giving you guys again a
hundred dollar
bonus refinance your student loans at
earnest.com
fighter terms condition supply once
again 100
buckaroos when you visit earnest.com
fighter
to refinance your student loan no not
available in all states okay
terms conditions apply visit earnest.com
fighter for more details
terms conditions fly earn a student loan
refinancing made by earnest operations
llc
nmls number one two zero four nine one
seven
california finance and law license
number six zero five four
seven eight eight two three second
street suite 401 north
san francisco california 94107 visit
earnest.com
licenses for a full list of licenses
again visit earnest.com
fighter first one okay so this is the
first
thing that i saw yesterday have you guys
seen anything
being posted about instagram censoring
our accounts
so tim kennedy posted this on his
instagram yesterday
saying that him and a bunch of other
people have had their
um interactions their engagement drop
drastically within the last few days and
they didn't know why
suddenly somebody went through their
settings on their profile
and realized that there was an extra
little tab where
it says you can filter out the type of
content you want to see
and the default is that they start
censoring a lot of the stuff that you're
looking at
you have to go out of your way to put
allow everything so you can see your
regular feeds
and so tim kennedy is saying that he's
lost 25
engagement and followers within the past
few days
sensitive control yeah it's on uh limit
default usually
so you gotta go you gotta go out of your
way to uncensor your um
i did this right after seeing this too
oh i'm gonna do that until unless
tim posted text gianni to make sure
mine's
not like this i'm going to do that i'm
glad he did that we're here it's very
interesting
it's not so they just don't tell anybody
yeah they didn't announce it it wasn't
until
these social media tech companies and
youtube they have so much power
it's scary well i think they're also in
some ways um
they're also let's do it after the show
right now
let's do it afterwards right now in the
middle of the show
come to a screeching halt
um
in fact you designed me a [ __ ] man
dragon merch let me look at my time
though
dude man i only make things that sell
bubbles dude can you imagine if it was
like an interactive one where you just
see my
it's like what the [ __ ]
if he was just going crazy please one
time guys i'm busy i gotta go
so they're doing to all accounts all
accounts yes [ __ ] and they don't tell
anybody
yeah and uh based off of that algorithm
they
limit the type of things you can see so
if instagram deems it as
inappropriate or uh something that is
age restricted then they'll limit your
post so a lot of
oh wow so a lot of people if you're like
a instagram dedicated to
cooking recipes then none of your stuff
is going to get flagged but if you're
like tim kennedy where he posts about
guns or if you're a comic maker or yeah
if you're a comic making inappropriate
jokes or just like [ __ ] around
what you put on there what you should do
is like a short sizzle
and it's like hey check out this joke
here the full one on youtube or
something when you do facebook ads
if you have one bad word or one
questionable thing you can get
completely [ __ ] really yeah man even
if you bleep it
it's a problem so they have too much
power i agree
i agree there's nothing we can do
there's always something you can do but
it might take a long time no it's
nothing like organize you know protest i
keep talking about it i mean but yeah
you're right
all right go go off youtube and uh they
can shut you down
no i'm saying but like if you want to
protest go off the go they can just do
this too
and then you need them they can do that
but that's what i'm saying like you
could protest them
and go off of it let me know how your
ticket sales go i know i hear you let me
know how your shows go
again when you can attack people's
ability to make a living that's how you
silence them that's how you censor this
it's called power
it's called no one has more power than
youtube or why because because five
companies control
all the communication because they're a
private company all right
i forgot about that are they yeah
they're a private company
here we go dude this woman has been on
the run since march
because she is connected to a murder and
recently so recently
um the oklahoma tulsa
police department posted on facebook
their criminal of the week
basically trying to promote uh different
criminals
so they could get them
so distracting
so the tulsa police department basically
posted her
saying hey if you know where this woman
is if you have any information
let us know and she actually commented
under that post
saying is there reward money for any
information
which then led to her getting caught and
this is the photo what perv
where's the money who's the reward money
yeah you better sell social media they
can track you
ain't gonna be as funny when you get
processed oh gosh
holy [ __ ] so she got caught by this yes
they were able to attract
that oh wow yeah eric graves was shot
and killed
in some apartments jesus christ she
looked
super friendly there she does look very
friendly that is
was her husband was that she was married
and he got killed what what is that no
she was an accessory to murder
she was an executive at these apartments
and she was
part of it i guess yeah it doesn't go
into too many details but
that's the photo that's going on it
ain't gonna be funny when you get
processed
but her name is lorraine graves and eric
graves
was shot and killed so she was
she must been related to eric graves and
i'm saying that might be her husband
for sure she's got a husband not anymore
he was murdered she's she's well
that's cool she doesn't she could keep
her
nutrition in that area okay well i
thought that was me at first
i wish your chest was like i guess a
bunch of fans were giving dax shepard
[ __ ] for
going on testosterone i guess he's
talked about it before on his podcast
and recently he said that after getting
on testosterone he just feels so much
better
now that he's an older guy and he's
always for the mid-40s
yeah i guess he went from one 80
something to
210 pounds once he got 30 pounds of
muscle yeah
here's what i was you know i was talking
about this morning about it
like so let's say you were to get blood
work
and you were deficient in vitamin c
would you take vit more vitamin c
take let's say you're deficient in
magnesium or whatever it is so if you
take blood work and you're deficient
in testosterone why wouldn't you take
testosterone to get to certain now i'm
not saying take so much that you blow up
and you're doing steroids
but if you're deficient in something i
don't get why there's this weird like
unspoken thing of testing testosterone
like why wouldn't he do it also feels
better better
also as we get more technologically
advanced and how to bio hack the body
all of us are going to be doing
something that i mean
it's going to be this is just the
beginning this is like crude stuff
pretty soon we're going to be able to
jack up your jeans but this makes sense
you talk about dax the guy who suffered
from depression suffered from addiction
you know and he's done crazy like he's
had so many concussions
he rides motorbikes [ __ ] does crazy
stuff work yeah so
he's had so i'm sure his testosterone
especially at his age and he's a busy
dude
so if his testosterone is [ __ ] why i
don't get why
why anybody give a flying [ __ ] if he
takes artificial people get a little
weird when it comes to
people doing educational aesthetics
they just don't know enough about it
because if he was you know
efficient in vitamin c vitamin a b
whatever it is and he took that would be
like what the [ __ ] dude why would you
take that it's like because i need to
i'm deficient it just happens
testosterone especially after the age of
30 starts to go downhill unless you're
me
you're still going strong look at you
when's that song you got checked out
though
i'm kidding i mean a while ago a hot
second while ago
but i mean i bet forever about a year
but i don't know i didn't
by the way i got tests i got one reading
it was really high but it's one reading
what what is your favorite all the [ __ ]
that you've been through because like
stress and all that work [ __ ] yourself
sure and what's dope about testosterone
too obviously i'm an advocate of it
also it's dope about testosterone so
let's say i don't sleep for like
which i haven't i haven't slept well in
three nights well that will
royally [ __ ] up your testosterone yes
but if you're artificially putting it in
it doesn't matter i can get through my
day i'm not my day's not
[ __ ] some artificial intelligence you
took a lot of [ __ ] head trauma you
also worked out like
it was your job you know you had low
testosterone when you were you know
playing football yeah yeah and and and
so you know i i just think
if if it makes you feel better then what
are we talking about but we got
people you got to understand it's not a
it's not steroids it's not performance
in hand what it is
is you're deficient in that so you're
bringing it
300 to a thousand so if you go and get a
test let's say chin's a hundred
well chin's not going to take so much
that his level's 4 thousand well then
you're on steroids
you're taking too much and you're going
to get all big and all these weird side
effects
chin's going to take enough to get him
to 500 a normal level
for a man of his age where he should be
so his energy is better his lean muscle
his body doesn't hurt he sleeps better
his appetite's better
his mental space is better not
everybody's taking the same amount
well if you're doing it from a legit
doctor you should be taking
a certain amount to get you to normal
levels yeah not
these weird crazy you feel if you do
your test
if you have a lot of tests and you feel
like like the minute i start to feel
like i don't have any or i'm low energy
and i'm doing everything i can to you
know naturally
i would 100 go on it i think you should
get your levels checked though
especially last year pretty good right
now but yeah i would
i would just check yeah 100 and by the
way it probably fluctuates
stress brings it down lack of sleep
brings down not eating well all that
stuff
no no doubt yeah i mean yeah i'm sure
chin could use a little i can tell from
there i
could tell from
that's uneducated so it's not real you
don't have to stay on it no you don't
there's stuff you can do that bring you
back to your normal levels
so if you take it for a year you like
actually don't feel good on this
there's other thing clomid other things
you can take that will ramp up your
testing start producing testosterone
naturally
so saying you've got to be on it forever
that's not true now if you misuse it
and you're going like your level is like
a thousand your body's like completely
[ __ ] well that
yeah you can probably still get back to
somewhat normal
but there's ways to do it dude is it
expensive though no not at all really no
holy crap cheaper than your prior
protein powder you get from on it i
don't even drink protein powder but
that's good but you want to do it with a
doctor's supervision of course i
wouldn't do it like outside
yeah there's some people like who are
really good at that who know how to
by people there's a million people are
good at it it's pretty upfront it's
pretty also pretty complicated and
go to an endocrinologist
you're talking a guy who's been you've
never done i'm talking the guy who's
been through it i know people are very
successful on it
you don't need to do it so you don't
have a lot of bubba i i know i
that you've never done that means zero
to me i've had long talks with rogan
about it i've had the long talks
me too talk to rogan about it right go
to an endocrinologist
way more complicated this is the guy
who's you know do you want to talk to
guys so she's been through the war
means nothing though bob it means
nothing i'm sorry hold on
there the it go to somebody who studies
the endocrine system which is what we're
dealing with when you're
going to maybe correct right that's all
i'm saying that would be that would be
an endocrinologist
you can do study stuff you can do more
gordon that guy's going to do that or
you can go to
actual testosterone therapy replacement
center who runs
that idea who runs all that stuff chin
who runs all that stuff
and they can tell the tell what your
levels are at uh there are a lot of
problems
thousands and thousands of people
successfully too bad
but talking about who's never done so so
this guy has never done it but talk to a
guy
no but i've had conversations with real
phds to help athletes cheat on it
yeah we help all the athletes okay like
big time guys weird
i was an athlete i know i had so long
so weird these doctors that he's
referred to yeah i've worked with
phds who are actually i've worked with
all haha
i know now hold on one of the things is
that your friends have them on their
podcast but no i've had private
conversations
so so a lot of times your your zinc and
magnesium selenium levels can be off
ooh bro and sometimes they'll bring
those levels back and your test
testosterone will shoot back to you how
old are you so you want to make sure you
want to make sure that you're doing that
first make sure you're doing that first
and working out and sleeping
and then see where your levels are there
and then see if you need more so there
are things you can do naturally
first that bring yourself back so if
you're not sleeping at all eating well
and you use it it can lead to issues are
you sleeping good jen
i do because of kratom which i don't
want to really
promote too much right but that's what i
do so how creative helps me sleep oh
i don't know was this for me yeah for
you yeah does that
help me sleep yeah it doesn't help you
sleep great no i take credit and get up
it's usually waiting so the lower doses
or is it the lower doses or stimulants
the higher doses
is for you know relaxation at least for
me
all right but i do sleep pretty well
i'll tell you this jen
your age is gonna be tough to eat
[ __ ] sprouts where the [ __ ] you want
to get your testosterone back i did my
test too and
my testosterone was actually pretty
decent it's pretty high
okay which is kind of a bummer because
you know what it is
yeah do you know what it was do you
remember what it was
i just remember when i they gave you a
call back and they said it's like at a
little bit above average that's all i
remember did you have different readings
just one this is through like just blood
work yeah because there there's the
floating testosterone
so stuff that you use there's your free
time it wasn't blood it was like the
swab
and then you just mail it in yeah yeah
oh yeah it also changed it says it's
pretty accurate
yeah yeah so you have to be fasted you
can't drink water or anything when you
do it
yeah and then yeah put into that little
vial and send it back right
oh yeah i think just one test is
sometimes not
for sure feel like for a week or
something
that's what i do i'm definitely i feel
like i can well you said testosterone
like starts going down like your 30s
like late 30s
how long you've been doing how many
months really
how much does it affect your um
everything's better really
yeah you always complained about having
low testosterone i didn't even complain
you never you never you always you know
why not do it if you know how it's also
not the end of the world you're not
[ __ ] it's not brain surgery yeah how
often do you have it's not that big of a
commitment
twice a week and is it injections or
what is it what do you have to go to the
doctor
do you do yourself i do i don't go you
don't want to go to the doctor every
time i've only heard i've only heard
positive things for the most part i know
the same
even actually if you look at the studies
of even like steroids
people who do steroids people think well
you're going to die early there's not a
lot of evidence that steroids is
a lot of long-term damage yeah it's
abuse that messes it up
you might as well give it a shot chin
i'm so down because
the thing i was scared of was when brian
mentioned that if you do it you have to
kind of like
no stay on it i thought that you said
that i think some people get a
psychological thing where they do it
and then once they get that the athletes
and stuff they're afraid to get off it
because how is their performance that's
right yeah
okay but i'm so down i'm gonna actually
talk to my doctor then
everybody's good or do you have to go to
doctor you say just go to a clinic right
you can go to clinic
or doctor it's tough if you go to a
doctor who doesn't really specialize i'd
rather go to a clinic yeah
i tried too bad yeah there's no need to
huh yeah yeah that's yeah that's why i
was thinking i was like i'd want to try
it but i don't want to start at your age
young enough
yeah could i start at 27. i would shave
that mustache
i feel like i can't trust you with my
kids
few people can pull off a mustache not
me if i wear a mustache i look like a
valkyrie
away from the high school oh here's the
exact facial hair as val kilmer from
tombstone
it's spot-on it's actually true bring it
up jen all right hold on i got to get
calendar by the way
you know what you look like you look
like falcomer's
brother there you go younger brother who
didn't there's a
no no like i oh my brother
was younger
that's a good call jesus that's minus
minus the alcohol that's a good
reference dude
you know what you are his [ __ ] well
isn't that
like that yeah i like that reference
those ends
that's a good [ __ ] that's a good look
how's the date in life been going kyle
it's been tough out here tell me about
the cheesecake factory girl
no yeah it wasn't good damn
she should have brought sushi and
cheesecake and it did not have a sparkle
it's the second [ __ ] date she said
there's not a sparkle yeah now
hold on where did you meet this girl
that was the first mistake
and you said let's go out did you guys
match how's it working
jump on uh chappelle's mic real quick
just jump on your belt
so yeah um hopefully she doesn't see
this but yeah we uh met the truck
so who went to a bar and then the second
i was like and i'll bring sushi and
cheesecake over you know we'll see you
know we have glasses of wine
so she said come over to my house she
said i'm bringing sushi
i just put a bunch of condoms in my
pocket and then you know
i'm like forks in there like i was ready
to go eat some cheesecake
the way he's stopped
are you trying to [ __ ] your pants at
this girl's house and just a
sushi pocket a stuffed pocket full of
[ __ ]
[Applause]
i got to the table i pulled out soy
sauce and a couple magnums and i put in
there
so the first date went good went great
that's why that's why i did all this
stuff for the second one so second one
she said why don't you come over you
went cool i'll bring sushi and
cheesecake
exactly and then come over and what
happens so we watched bob burgers
had four glasses of wine so i was
feeling it you know
she had four two oh yeah i mean we were
four so you're like man
it's a bottle each and it's a bottle
yeah four glasses yeah yeah yeah
so yeah and then you know where she's
like oh it's getting late i was like
yeah it is and uh that was her son
yeah she's like get the bug out um yeah
i hadn't you know hadn't
pressed anything i was like yeah she's
like well what do you think and i was
like how about what
she's like i just don't feel a spark i
was like could you tell me that at seven
o'clock i could have been in bed at nine
i got an
hour drive home she needed five hours to
figure out this is real wasabi [ __ ]
she's like i just think i need some
space i said it's the second date
so what are you talking about she just
was in the truck see yeah so i'm just
i'm gonna
you know just go back out there that's
why that's why i shaved my beard true
that's no that's what it is she just
wasn't feeling
you don't waste your like too much time
yeah like lisa was like date
seven [ __ ] man my my buddy this is this
is the second date
what what she was a white girl yeah yeah
and yeah sometimes all really pretty
just
you know this girl this girl kicked this
guy i know
out of this is recent and she said get
the [ __ ] out
you you know he'd been caught doing some
stuff she goes get out
and he was like okay and she was like i
said get up he's like oh yeah i'm just
gonna get my stuff
and another thing and she then talked to
us and she's like
he's [ __ ] acting like and i go he's
just he you let him go
he didn't want to be in this
relationship he's not upset
that's the [ __ ] hard thing to really
sometimes people just didn't fight it
yeah didn't fight for you shoot or shoot
dude keep taking swings man
what's up with some headphones though
why didn't from the 1990s
oh so what did you can i ask you a
question when you went out so how would
you get off my dick
we find out kyle's all mean y'all get
off my dick everybody
what did you wear over there um for the
for the bob's burger and i was very
very comfortable you know i had like
just a nice t-shirt on some sweatpants
they were gray sweatpants sweatpants
they were relaxing you know so just
sweatpants like the this is easy to rip
off like just
like the ripples
what about when you got to her apartment
like
how did it go still in the graveyard so
you're i'm not a guy who dresses well
they make fun of me
but i don't know i'm just looking you
got those jean shorts on you got some
you got black sneakers with those
black uh socks with those sneakers
hipster very hipster
you would know very silver legs let me
see without your with your hat off
no it's not good right now i've had this
hat on all day well you lose that you
have hair or dude
oh yeah yeah i do but it's just and he's
a nice guy like kyle's a catch and he
you know i appreciate that
yeah yeah yeah she would shoot ladies
drives a tesla yeah
cute good with the videos like all my
videos see
it's come from five five in heels so you
guys are watching
you're not
i'm going to put all this on my on my
profiles got a val camera
moustache from the nose nose to the chin
you look like val kilmer
right so there's a couple inches of your
face it looks like val kilmer when he
was in his prime
it happened i would get mistaken for
ryan gosling
that makes sense yeah yeah you have do
you have cos is ryan gosling short what
you got
nope nope uh he's not huge i think he's
about my height but you got you got
i think something right and you got
about a handsome devil he's handsome
um but uh so are you have you
are you back on tinder though don't let
it get you down man oh sweet
probably that night you were swiping
tinder i thought hinge was the one
i call hinge binge because everyone's 80
pounds overweight
oh god damn not good yeah i didn't know
that
against it are you into bigger girls
though
come on now you're bigger than me but um
we're in california like how are you
225 plus at 5-2 yeah it's a bad number
those numbers are tough those numbers
are tough to work with not unless you're
into that but what what is uh
what is your type um you know definitely
shorter than me i've tried taller how
tall are you i'm like
probably like five four five five i
think there's a lot of
five one five two girls yeah that's
that's what i prefer
you know what i bet i bet you get a uh
latina pregnant in the next year uh
at the gym i have been i have not gotten
any lifts done
interesting what are we in [ __ ] july
hopefully not i do not need children
it's happening yeah welcome to college
now do you where do you work out
um i just got a membership at gold's gym
in valencia
and it is it's like shakira city up
there it's poppin
yeah and he's in zoo all the time
filming us so yeah and i'm the smallest
person in zoo for sure like
the dog has more striation than i do and
it's a pit bull
boys in there yeah yeah so uh so i had
to get a you know a membership at gold's
and a lot of women there
yeah but you know i'm like i'm like hey
you done using the 15 pound dumbbells
like
i've been out of the gym for a while so
i'm not at my you know we're on pr and
every week
it works now we'll figure it out so
we'll see
you're about to you're about to have a
small pond in cincinnati now you're in a
big pond yeah you're gonna latina main
reason we're out here though is follow
thick
boy youtube channel so i can keep my job
kind of stay out here thank you so much
subscribe like follow brendan comment
come on to
the ontario improv dates at the end of
this month july 29th 30 30.
i'll [ __ ] these hoes anyways i'm out
here [ __ ] promoting big boy
productions
i love it god bless what else you got
jen oh by the way i told kyle too
when he first told me about the date i'm
like go for the kiss the first day
i honestly think that's the move you got
to be careful though i mean
i mean he's a young dude in the room he
said it was going good 20 21 goes for
this
is that his first day was going through
this environment you got to just be
careful about going
yeah you gotta ask you call
no i wouldn't say that but i said go for
the kiss i'll ask the girls here what do
you guys think
cat like if you're both if you're having
a good time feel it from her
i left stevie's apartment right after he
kissed me i was like oh i gotta go home
i gotta watch
the next day i was not trying to do that
oh
she's with stevie now i'm gonna stevie
now but there you go
paris what's up you're single and you're
young like if if you're on a first
if you're on and then you're hitting it
off and there's like you know motions
are run
sparks flying if these lights are flying
well you like attract
them if would you i'm interested yeah i
mean you gotta it just depends how it's
going
i have to read it i feel like i i mean
it's clear i feel like i'm trying to be
clear about it you know
yeah up front i try to be well there's
certain like gestures you know
you kiss that would you lean in you
would not be the aggressor yeah
no yeah what about a kill from the
calendar you're not using
because i don't have an aggressor were
you the aggressor with stevie
with stevie no stevie was very much the
one chasing me
i feel like if i don't like you that
much i'm more aggressive
i'm more passive if i actually like you
because i'll [ __ ] right away if i don't
talk about you
i don't care if i like you too much
it's so funny that's fair you check out
her only fans
oh this is sucky but oh this one was
kind of scary
so there is a music festival happening
in miami called
rolling lao the first day is today
yesterday while
a bunch of people were testing out all
the equipment making sure that
everything was going to be good for this
weekend
one of the projectors from uh one of
their performance stages collapsed
holy [ __ ] jesus they're saying that
nobody got hurt it was a freak accident
and the show was still going to continue
anyone showed up it was yesterday the
first day is today
loud organizers were seen covering up
the area with what looks to be a black
talk
someone's hurt that's good one day
before the much anticipated
jesus christ rolling loud quickly put
out this statement on social media a
screen
uh on the news a screen fell down at one
of our
stages i'm i'm not showing up i'm not
going
to be careful can you imagine if you're
on this performance
uh monster truck jam at staples centers
that [ __ ] is intense you ever been to
one of those brian no well think about
it staples center which isn't that big
and these giant [ __ ] the biggest trucks
in the world yeah and they're
so loud we have to wear the earmuffs
really so loud
yeah they want a gravedigger yeah he's
still popping yeah yeah remember that
one
different driver than when we were a kid
but yeah the family still owns it oh for
real all right
that's like that's like the main one
isn't it yeah gravediggers number one by
far
i was gonna wear my indians jersey today
well they changed it they officially
changed the name to the guardians
uh cleveland guardians the guardians of
the galaxy cleveland guardians oh yeah
they just did it before they were going
to get is the indian is it indian or
is it native american you want to say
like you said if you said the cleveland
native americans it'd be different than
cleveland native americans is better
than the guardians
of the guardians what's their the native
americans would be great what's the life
they did this before they didn't get
[ __ ] because the redskins changed their
mascot which was the red so what are
they defensive yeah yeah that's little
effects
that's been i remember that being a
topic of conversation
in 1985 when i was
in dc dude i remember being redskins
step in and be like who are they playing
my dad's like it's the cowboys versus
the redskins i was like god that doesn't
sit right
yeah at seven yeah this is nike i
remember that and they would always do
it and then they would always be like
yeah whatever [ __ ] off and then
the the indians though so they slowly
went away from benny the i think his
name was benny the
the indian i think the mascot yeah the
best logo of all time i think
but then now they're the guardians do we
know again what's their logo
if you play this what does it show the
logo i don't know but you know tom hanks
is the one that's doing the voiceover
for this too oh [ __ ] they
they went all chat but that's fine we
are a city on the rise
into the future from our iron down past
we are a city of fire and water is tom
hanks from cleveland of trees
no idea i think he might build through
generations of blue collars
and the bride of scotland cleveland's
are great all of those who have worked
harder
we hold tight to our roots and set our
sights on tomorrow
[Music]
and this is our team that has stood with
our city for more than a century
from old municipal to the corner of
carnegie just shows all white guys it's
a team that has seen his own progress
and prosperity its history flows like
the river through the heart of the city
the history that has given us miraculous
moments
moments that spanned years and others
sports
moments that broke barriers and moments
that broke hearts
moments that prove this is more than a
game
we remember those moments as we move
forward with change
you see there's always been cleveland
that's the best
part of our name i know it's time
to unite as one family we're the
guardians
keep going chin it's cool that's good is
that it
i'm on board but they're together we are
all
cleveland guardians garda
i'm tom hanks garda it's in it's ei and
they kept the end of the word
yeah indy into for guard
guardian get your guard up dude i'd like
to see the logo the
guardian you're crazy if you don't think
i'm still going to rock my indians
jersey it has the big [ __ ]
indian probably going to be worth a lot
of money there's a disc out there
because they're trying to get rid of the
indian logo
oh oh that's the logo right there looks
like it the guardian
collector collector's item my high
school was the warriors they had to
change it
you can't be called the warriors
warriors what's wrong with what high
school's the warriors
well i mean they were just saying they
were having trouble with it for a while
because of the native americans and
i think when i was i mean this was
probably like 2015.
2016 when i was still there uh there was
a w
and that was the logo the w with the
spear through it and they had to change
that because it was a fight
so they've been dealing with it i mean
jesus christ can't do anything i mean
jesus christ
because the native americans didn't use
the warriors the warrior native
americans
didn't use spears okay all right i don't
know it's still the same
really my high school this is this is
hijacked
being hijacked by the most extreme
elements than the most sensitive and
because
is that the it's called i guess you can
call a native american indian it's
offensive
i i mean yeah because indian was from
india no indian wasn't was a western
term for
you know somebody who was there so that
that wasn't the name that they gave
themselves
like the sue the comanche the apache
they had their own language and then
they were that's fine
generally indians i wouldn't fight all
right is the term blackhawk offensive
because i know chicago is not changing
when you say it sounds racist i know it
doesn't sound bad when you say yeah
i was fine for 38 years
black ops when you say i don't like you
too much i was like
you say black hawk and you emphasize
black and i don't like it black
if you said they're not i guarantee you
black hawks the next ones to change they
will no they won't
no no team has changed their uh no nhl
team has ever caved to that they will
not
blackhawks blackhawks is just a black
hawk it's a hawk that's well they're
yeah that [ __ ] is lit best jerseys in
the league
one of them one of them the chief
black hawk yeah that's a trickier one
mm-hmm that might they might be
that one's almost a tribute to a
blackhawk indian that's changed that's
why i'm
wondering maybe that's why they is there
any other team they say the chicago
blackhawks won't change nickname because
oh you know what name was lit as [ __ ]
and clearly had to change it because so
much violence in the city
the [ __ ] washington bullets oh
jesus did they change it oh yeah
quite some time ago yeah yeah the
bullets was lit they're the wizards now
oh well they've been the ones yeah
they've been there so it says it won't
change it because it
honors the life of an actual native
american you know it's it is
what it is hey language i think if
there's any other teams
i can smell my armpits there's really no
other team i i am
yeah there's really no other teams with
the indian reference
yeah uh pirates of pittsburgh pirates
that's not
we can make fun of pirates um until
until like old like
people who are who have one eye patch
and a peg like we find this i
don't i don't think this is very nice i
talk like a pirate and i have a pair of
pirates
no because like because of all the [ __ ]
they did i'm saying like i'm surprised
they're not going to find some issue
with people
well i'm a patriot so paige but what
they did what i'm saying
like what patriot patriots the brooklyn
dodgers which are now the l.a dodgers is
the dodgers because you dodged the draft
no no i don't think so no oh definitely
not
that's not where it comes from because
do you think the vikings would change
eventually
does that count as one you know what's
interesting about the vikings is yeah
because you know
there's no trolley dodgers attached to a
brooklyn ball club due to the complex
maze
trolley cars that weaves its way through
the boat oh interesting i think shows
that are dodging the draft
anyways uh sounds like glue right the
draft we don't go to war um so you know
there's no evidence
anywhere that vikings had horns on they
never were i didn't know
it's with horns that's all made believe
that's not real so they could cancel the
vikings because
the swedish who are the vikings they
know they get they're superman they're
gonna be like what the [ __ ]
but i can't think of anything else that
like vikings a little because they don't
they never
that's not real yeah
that's an irish fight yeah irish fight
they're short with red hair yeah
yeah try to think what else there's
nothing really else
i don't know sports there's gotta be
some colleges out there that are still
for sure with indian names for sure what
do you what
else do you got yeah buccaneers pirates
yeah buccaneers though
buccaneer you know that was usually a
white
person 49ers the gold rush
yeah so a previous guest
on fighter and the kid is now 60 million
richer
who they call her daddy girl she left a
spotify
how crazy is that podcast deal for 60
mil
and i know for a fact she made more than
60 mil probably yeah no i know oh wait
but that sounds
freaking insane i did the deal she made
more oh wow yeah
so what's interesting for females yeah
huge wow
so what's in so the way barstool did it
you know barstool's network
they would pay her a salary so they were
giving her like 500 000
and then she was like oh cool and her
contract was up and then spotify because
she
as far as female goes she's the biggest
in the space she's like dak shepard or
rogan for females basically her
show's huge wow so she was like very
cool and the spotify is like here's i'm
gonna say how much they gave her
here's 60 million for all sakes of the
story and she's like i'm gonna go over
here
so the 500 000 a year i'm gonna go over
here because i own the ip i'm gonna take
my show over here in my audience
wow and her her cope whatever her coat
was before yeah she was giving them crap
that's what happened
that's what happens when your boyfriend
is your manager and goes you're the star
of the show
terrible this girl who she's actually
really smart
you know i know she engineers too she
engineers she produces she does she
edits
she does everything wow so that girl
who's like oh i'm the star of the show
she's like cool story now she's worth
way more money
yeah that's insane look at that that's
impressive that's a dope story
what does she do she interviews people
or what is her oh it's it's
called her daddy she's talking about
like hooking up with guys what it used
to be
it started off with her and her co-host
they would talk about like their
sex life and then it slowly started to
become interviews with people ever since
their split happened
and now i think it's going in a
different direction after it goes to
spotify beautiful gal yeah yeah we had
on fire with the kid but you weren't
here i forget what you're doing probably
it's me and santino
she's great though yeah that's cool she
does
the spotify just going oh yeah thank you
for playing
i have to pee really bad go for it yeah
yeah you got to
spit that go ahead no no no no i don't
know how are you going to reenact
bridesmaids
back back from that hot lava drop yeah i
didn't have no hot lava drug i had to
pee
dogs oh
remember when we were going to starbucks
do you mind he should think of [ __ ] he'd
get me every time like
no matter where it was you'd walk in the
starbucks when we've been on tortillas
like stomach okay stomach's falling he's
got a poop do you have a bathroom
he gets embarrassed but he had to really
poo we'll have two coffees please
and actually can you have coffee
and i just feel like and the other
people would be listening i'd be like
[ __ ] dude please
i'm very hard to embarrass but that
would [ __ ] kill me what's this
deandre hopkins yeah one of the best
players in all the league you know about
this
playing for the cardinals now he is yep
oh wow
played last year you know you love
football yeah that's why i said oh wow
what's the story though so they i guess
the whole team received a memorandum
saying that they want people
on the team to get coveted shots yeah he
doesn't want to get a coveted shot so
he's
considering even retiring if they force
him to do it but it's also they're also
saying like they're not forcing
here's the other thing though so if your
team has certain amount of positive
covet tests you for you don't even get
to play
you're forfeit yeah wow a lot of money
online
all the money on that tells me like get
your [ __ ] shot most but i think
most nfl teams are 85 vaccination
dude in italy they they're making it
mandatory and there are
massive demonstrations they're just like
[ __ ] you
so i never thought i would say this but
be in a position to hurt my team because
i don't want to
partake in the vaccines making question
my future nfl here's my thing and you
don't want to play that bad
because in all in all reality the
vaccination whatever you believe about
it
you know it's pretty safe well there's
so much information online
like so much misinformation
disinformation mal information whatever
especially after american community
though it's like it it causes
it causes infertility it causes cancer
it causes it there's all these things
that's the problem with well this is the
problem with misinformation right
there but did you see that there's that
thing there well there's conspiracy
theories but there's that thing where
the cd
came out where they showed it and then
took it down that i think 5 000 people
have died from getting the vaccination
but a lot of people die i mean a lot of
people have adverse reactions to all
vaccines including aspirin including
other medicines right you got to
you got to give people the information
yeah yeah you gotta get people that you
wanna can you hide it that's when people
go whoa gotta give people the
information
but i i am personally you know
pro-vaccine for the most part i do
understand
why people are reticent i don't think
the scientific community has done a good
job
really of of combating all these other
sort of like
these other rumors and these of this
other information doesn't help with
pouching the emails
it doesn't it does none of it helps so i
don't know uh
yeah i get it but to him it's like so
you're willing to retire over the
vaccine
you don't want to play that bad i mean
he's so good how much how much does he
make do you think a year how much does
it cost
oh dude i mean you're talking about the
top guy how much what'd you say
let's say yeah 15 million jab me as much
as you're jamming the dick jack
right my dick dude you got me in my pee
hole and every day go
jab jab i'm sorry so base salary uh sign
bus 9 million
a cap 12 uh oh
you can you could jab that needle my
tongue every sunday i'll jab it what
everybody says every sunday is that
being rich as [ __ ]
uh [ __ ] give it to me i want all the
[ __ ] jazz go to the highest paid
receiver go back to
let me see he's up there he's so [ __ ]
good you can get me right in the taint
right i'll lift my ball up well he's
27.2 million dollars he's the highest
favorite i'll [ __ ] you right now and and
smile while i'm doing it damn i will
lick your ass
right now i would i will lick your old
ass over and i'll lick your [ __ ] and
then i'll
i'll just give you a good old suck off
and then i'll kiss you oh yeah oh man
yeah what oh sorry you took it you're
still doing this for the money oh yeah
no no no no wait no i don't sorry yeah
no i want
i'm all punched up wait so i i i
shouldn't get the vex
no because you that's where it's dicey
like if you've had covet they say
like you have lifetime they think you
have like because there's something that
happens in the
marrow of the bone where like you have
lifetime immunity that's typical with a
lot of
diseases yeah yeah so you so it's better
than getting the vaccine but they still
don't care they still want you to get a
vaccine
um yeah and i and if you if you don't
get the vaccine i'm sorry
i don't care what no i'm saying no eat a
dick
where were we going oh yeah no brian
what would you say i don't even know
what i was saying let me yeah
i get all punched up cause i still have
covert head i got covered brains made me
all foggy makes
sorry about this all right i gotta go
pick up my clothes
all right i gotta go pick my daughter up
now that i've been talking oh
buddy this is it uh next week wait
you're
are you coming to tacoma are you still
yeah [ __ ] off
uh tacoma next week thursday friday
saturday chappelle
david lucas myself big j shot will be
there
kyle with his mustache will be there
ladies if you're looking for a short
king over there kyle good with the
camera you want to see what it's like to
kiss val kilmer yes
short val kilmer next thursday friday
saturday tacoma washington i'm in north
carolina august 19th
21st la jolla comedy store august 27th
29th
san jose california september 9th
through the 11th the big boys san
antonio texas september 24th through the
25th
one show each night all right that's it
for me uh i got ontario
uh california improv got the houston
texas improv i thought i had all my
dates up there are you sure that's the
one
i'm a refresher there we go
san diego california
yeah [ __ ] houston texas improv august 19
2021 buffalo new york that buffalo
helium is great they're great you've
done it yes
and how you ate the real actual wings
i've not eaten the wings but i what are
you doing
this is buffalo wings buffalo new york
that's where they created brilliant but
you can't go to the original place
original place sucks okay there's
another place
jay knows what it is all right the best
wings in the world really
okay not better than uh what's my spot
okay
oh somebody came to my show at haas and
go shop we drew
we drove to [ __ ] arizona to eat jt's
wings because you said they're so good
they go you hyped up so much they
weren't good there's some place in the
in
uh in like van nuys they said it's the
best wings of all time
really they drove all the way to arizona
just for the wings well of course
they're gonna say i'm doing my day
you're back driving five minutes oh yeah
yeah i don't call chicago though yeah i
know i know don't go it's 40 minutes
outside of chicago it's an hour outside
it's [ __ ] like suburbs it's the south
only place to play though i know i just
have this country there's nothing
which is nuts they don't have a place
well they have a zany's there they got a
lot factory they got but
they don't take they don't do weekends
oh that's not your home that's my home
well that's my mom too and my
and my your mom and i have i told my mom
and uh don't go to your show now being
your mom and i have you're still trying
to stack them hey bro
we have a thumb oh god i would never do
that i would never
be disrespectful and stack we have a
whole thing and i
one time now whatever colorado comedy
works
september 23rd 24th 25th that's the mama
i'm coming
no the man dragon is coming mama i'm
going to come here
you're not from there dude i am i know
but i'm kind of like it's sort of my
city because i left my mark on well
we'll see if i can get you in
hey hey bro we'll see if i let you in i
blaze a trail i go in there and they're
like
man dragon man dragon banners or
whatever yep and then uh
and by the way uh uh roughhouse fridays
this just dropped
uh giving you a good example i don't
know giving you an educated guess on
what we interviewed matt sarah oh man
sarah
what a terrible [ __ ] not sarah mike
brown don't want to listen to that no no
it's good it's a
podcast and if you want to bet on the
fights and guess what i'm betting on
where's my money going
i have no clue dj
after listening to me i listened to some
other people on the podcast rough house
paradise
go to that hey man don't make that face
uh i gotta go man
chappelle where are you gonna be oh [ __ ]
august 26th it's me and
[ __ ] dude it's okay august 26th uh
bray improv did some stuff in october
then you got tampa
side splitters and then uh dc loft
in october october i don't want to go to
oh yeah all right kids get your tickets
at f a t k z dot com or thickboy.com for
myself
new think boy video drops this sunday on
the vlog baby baby
kyle put it together so we don't like it
send them the hate
all right we're out yeah